we love superhero movies but sometimes
filmmakers seem to think that because
the movies feature superheroes they
don't have to feature logic or reason
from hiding critical clues and the
stupidest places to plain old boneheaded
plot holes here are some superhero movie
moments that make absolutely no sense
Howard Starks terrible clues Iron Man 2
was bloated to begin with but the big
twist was one of the dumbest plot points
possible Tony discovers the new element
he needs at just the right time thanks
to Clues hidden by his dear old dead dad
Howard I built this for you and someday
you'll realize that it represents a
whole lot more than just people's
inventions it represents my life's work
but that's incredibly lucky timing
especially considering how it hit is
clues in one of the most random ways
possible embedding a cryptic message to
Tony in an old home movie reel which
then unlocks an even more cryptic clue a
hidden side the old stark Expo design
but considering the clues were being
kept top secret by Nick Fury himself
could in how would have just you know
written Tony a letter with the info or
maybe just a note on the fridge that
would have been way way easier to find
why not use Quicksilver all the time
introducing a speedster can make for
awesome effects and cool set pieces but
it also creates more than a few plot
problems as viewers of x-men Days of
Future Passed found out sure the
Quicksilver super speed scene is easily
the coolest moment at a very good movie
but why on earth would Professor X
sideline Quicksilver for the rest of the
movie after getting a peek at his
abilities Quicksilver can take out every
enemy in the movie before they even know
they're in a fight but after getting
Quicksilver to help free Magneto Xavier
and future Wolverine just send him back
to his basement for the rest of the film
that seems not so smart why wait for the
house party fans might be mixed on Iron
Man 3 but there's no denying the film
did a great job of putting Tony Stark
outside his comfort zone and telling a
story unlike pretty much every other
Iron Man movie we just have one head
scratcher why didn't he just pull out
the house party protocol sooner and get
that army of super suits out of their
hidey holes he spends most of the film
trying to repair and reacquire his
latest suit but he apparently has
emergency protocol all this time I can
get an army of autonomous iron guys in
the air why not flip a lever a while
back yes they needed to excavate the
mansion to get a path cleared but it
doesn't take that long just four could a
man-sized hole down to the lab doesn't
logos without logic it's hard to deny
that Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
what a blow could mess and one of the
film's biggest problems is that it tries
to shoehorn in all sorts of setup for
Justice League at the expense of the
Batman vs. Superman story the most
ridiculous example when Diana was
checking out Lex Luthor's super secret
disc drive she finds files on pretty
much all the future Justice League
members complete with little logos that
Lex apparently designed for them in his
free time and then spends five minutes
watching the equivalent of a bunch of
YouTube clips while Gotham and
metropolis are being ravaged by
supervillains come on lady
focus up the Franciscan Dundrum one of
the big jokes in Deadpool is the fact
that waited sneakily figures out that
Ajax as real name is Francis then
proceeds to call him not just to piss
him off it's a name like Francis Francis
it's legally Ajax from the dish soap
when Wade gets loose later and sets off
on his revenge mission he starts hunting
down all of Ajax is known associates by
asking for Francis it's great and funny
except since the entire point is that
Ajax doesn't want anyone to know his
real name none of the people Deadpool is
torturing should have any idea who he's
talking about
if Deadpool had simply told any of them
that he was looking for Ajax rather than
Francis maybe the whole movie could have
been wrapped up in under 15 minutes
fortunately for fans it wasn't Batman's
healing factor Christopher Nolan's Dark
Knight trilogy is one of the seminal
film franchises in comic book history
but even the mighty Nolan can stretch
things a bit too far case in point the
fact that Oldman Batman in the Dark
Knight Rises is somehow stronger and
more physically capable than any version
of The Dark Knight we've seen up until
then despite having a busted knee and a
broken back not to mention he's been a
retired invalid for almost a decade
meaning he should be woefully out of
shape yes one appointment with a prison
chiropractor later and
goes from super couch potato to
unbeatable one popular orb Marvel's
guardians of the galaxy it's so darn fun
that it's hard to actually nitpick much
of anything but watch it a few times and
the themes start to show one of the
biggest is the points that actually
kicks off the whole movie star-lord
strips two more rags to retrieve that
orb which is actually an infinity stone
if this thing is in such high demand why
hasn't anyone retrieved it before and
what kind of crazy coincidence is it
that after being ignored for untold
centuries everyone literally shows up at
the exact same moment looking for it how
do you know about this I don't even know
what that is I'm just a junker man I'll
just check it out
director James gonna try to hand wave
this in the commentary track saying the
planets had tidal seasons our last
hundreds of years so everyone is showing
up because this is the first time the
orb hasn't been underwater in 300 years
that unlikely explanation might get him
a no price for Marvel but since it's not
actually in the movie it doesn't really
count congratulations you're another
lucky no prize winner you'll find it
enclosed and close it open it up the
envelope was empty thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
you
[Applause]